he told me to complete my training to
find the demons head you already have
Bruce I'm the one you seek I'm the demon
said I am racial group buddy now it's
okay so now
[Music]
hey everybody so Gotham just went full
smallville season eight or season nine
where Clark was actually wearing the
costume full Batman Begins Batman year
one however you want to think about it
so this would be my finale video there
was a whole bunch of stuff it's
basically season four everybody gets a
costume everybody gets a comic book
origin story really where the show
should have started a couple years ago
if they would have just started here I
feel like their audience would be twice
as big so Gotham looks like it's going
to be pretty badass in season four and
it's moving to Thursday night so I'll
remind people about that when we get to
the fault it won't premiere till
September let's talk about all the comic
book stuff all the origin stories and
all the cool stuff that's happening next
season so number 10 the court of owls is
seemingly destroyed they get rid of the
tej virus so if you remember during
Batman Begins Rachael Ghul wants to
spread the fear toxin to cleanse Gotham
of all the wickedness Gotham said that
the court of owls was doing a version of
that the virus came from Mad Hatter's
sister Alice who died in a previous
season but the people who were exposed
to her blood it would just drive them
crazy so Hugo Strange develops a new
version of the toxin to spread around
the city but also develops the antidote
that helps them out later the virus was
really just an excuse for a bunch of
main characters to go bonkers like the
lead character went off the rails when
Gordon got dosed with the virus he just
chewed through all of his scenery so it
was kind of fun for a little while but
thankfully that didn't last the biggest
lasting impact of that storyline was
that they used it to turn Nathaniel
Barnes like he gets dosed with the virus
into the executioner from the comics so
he's going to judge the wicked so he
just goes completely nuts but number 9
Alfred killed the shaman who's the
leader of the court of owls making Bruce
go nuts because he's been brainwashed
just a little bit but that's only the
beginning of people going nuts number 8
Gordon kills fish Mooney and it seems
like it's going to stick this time in
fact as she's dying she sort of has this
funny line of dialogue where she says
I've done it enough times to know when
my numbers up so I feel like they just
brought Jada Pinkett Smith back to give
penguin his origin story so in the way
that the leader of the core
about people like Rachel Ghul are there
to give Batman training help him become
who he's supposed to become I think that
that was what fish Mooney was for
penguins character so she served her
purpose she can go off into the distance
now I wasn't a huge fan of that
character but Jada pinkett-smith is a
great actress so I think she did what
she could with the stuff that they gave
her but number seven Batman
seeks out Rachel Ghul at the behest of
the shaman who seems like he was working
in conjunction with the League of
Assassins so the court of owls is tied
to the League of Assassins but the court
has gone in Rachel Ghul says that he's
trying to help Batman become his next
heir he's not quite ready yet
but number six is part of his training
one of the first big steps he gets him
to kill Alfred then teaches them how to
heal him with the waters of the Lazarus
Pit it's just an example of Bruce
letting go of the things that he holds
on to because Alfred is like his second
father we know the man he'll become but
Rachel Ghul is all about getting him to
cut ties with Gotham Rochelle Goyle
disappears saying that our time will
come so he's going to be one of the big
villains of season 4 but he's also
talking about them training during
Batman Begins so the timeline is still
intact Bruce is still very young he's
doing Batman year one stuff but he won't
become Batman till he actually goes
through that training that he gets Nanda
Parbat during Batman Begins so we'll
circle back around to that that's a
really important idea like where is the
line between Batman year one and Bruce
just running around punching people in
alleyways so number five killing spree
Barbara kills butch but we learn that
his name is secretly Cyrus gold
aka Solomon Grundy letting us know that
he's going to be coming back in a big
way Solomon Grundy born on a Monday
christened on a Tuesday married on a
Wednesday took ill on Thursday grew
worse on Friday died on Saturday buried
on Sunday that was the end of Solomon
Grundy so number four the penguin has
mr. freeze trapper Riddler in a block of
ice and uses them Han Solo Carbonite
style in Jabba's palace in the newly
minted iceberg lounge from the comics so
that everybody can just enjoy him while
they're having fun doing evil things
so right now iceberg lounge team penguin
is basically all the metahumans that
were following fish Mooney so you have
Mr Freeze poison
IV Firefly any new evil metahumans they
bring on in season four penguin is the
de facto ruler of the Gotham underworld
right now so most of the cool new
metahumans you see pop up will pass
through the iceberg lounge but number
three this is actually a lot of fun
Tabitha fries Barbara with a thousand
volts giving her a version of her Harley
Quinn origin story so this is the thing
a lot of people like you can't turn
Barbara into Harley Quinn Ben McKenzie
confirmed that we would see a version of
Harley Quinn in the finale and I believe
that this is what he was talking about
she was already off the rails
they BBQ her so now her skin just
changes a few shades they'll probably
lighten it up with some makeup we'll see
what she looks like in season four we're
number two now the Tabitha doesn't have
a partner anymore Catwoman walks in in a
version of her comic book costume and
gets the whip so just like Batman she's
slowly embracing her persona I want more
she's actually pursuing a goal we'll
probably see her stealing a lot of
things running around town bumping into
Bruce on rooftops but number one
Bruce goes full Batman year one
Smallville style in a scene nearing
Crime Alley when his parents died so you
see them pan up and he's looking over
the city he rips the mask off this is
sort of their Batman year one moment so
this is what he's going to be doing next
season so it just seems like next season
is going to be way more fun but you can
see how they're giving him the Batman
persona in the Smallville way so like
the last couple seasons of Smallville
Clark didn't wear the comic book costume
he wore a version of it that was very
close and did a lot of Superman things
in Metropolis but he was just like right
there on the edge of officially being
Superman so that's what's going on with
Batman but as for Rachael ghoul I know
people are like what do you think about
him versus the arrow version of Rachel
cool so in the brief scene that we've
seen him in I do like the way they
treated the character a little better
than the way the arrow did I like the
actor better Alexander siddig is great
but I like the more comic-book accurate
look so just like the costume the way
they do is make up the way they do is
hair looks much closer to the comics and
their lazarus pit glows green which
arrows did not I don't know why they
chose to do it that way but it was a
great episode I feel like if Gotham had
been this good this whole time then
people be talking about it more often
well let me know what you guys think of
the finale what you're excited for in
season 4
it feels a lot more like a Batman show
and less like a show with Batman
characters in it what's going to happen
next is they just drop the promo for
Gotham season four so I might do a video
for that you can let me know about that
in the comments but a lot of you have
asked for a video on the flash button
storylines so I'll probably do that as
well but here's some really cool DC TV
news they just cast Isis from the Black
Adam Shazam comics for legends of
tomorrow season three so because I
haven't done a legend season 3 video yet
I haven't done arrow Deathstroke like
there's a Deathstroke spin-off series
that the new Ben is trying to get going
we'll try to get that stuff out in the
next couple days but we also learned a
whole bunch of stuff about the Marvel
Netflix series happening next year like
daredevil season 3 so there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on and there's a
big Batman twist in the comic that's
coming out tomorrow so I'll probably do
a reaction video for that on Wednesday
but just be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave all your requests
in the comments below while you wait for
everything you can click here for brand
new Game of Thrones footage and you can
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight